the first thing i did
i'm doing it through my phone are you
gonna lie do it yeah
so i'll let them know you're doing it
okay okay
no but i got it
oh
can you text nathan aslan and ask him if
he's got sickness
or carrie roper either one
we have seen them
uh
oh
i can't get to it i'm lost okay that's
my
okay
thank you
thank you
thank you good morning everybody thank
you for being here this morning
i want to start off by making a request
police uh
parking is very limited in this facility
and obviously we're very concentrated on
trying to make sure that you know we've
been out of here safely and continue to
count dollars
in mind that we're going to be adding
security at all of our entrances
and we'll only be granting access to
those who
are approved members of the media
members of my staff and those
individuals who have
business with the election department so
please keep that in mind
the purpose of being here this morning
is to get some clarification on exactly
what the work is between done here in
clark county to get the votes counted
and accurately
i have counts now
on what we received from the election
day drop-offs
the u.s postal service on election day
and yesterday
and also some additional ballots that we
had pending
because we had to stop processing begin
getting ready for election day support
so on election day at the drop-off
locations in all book centers on the
election department there were 34
743 ballots dropped off
the u.s postal service as a election
date and yesterday
brought to us 4208 ballots
and there were 24 311 ballots
that we're pending when we stop
processing to get ready for election day
so that brings us to a total of 63 262.
today staff is preparing to count and
has already begun counting
a little over 51 000 dollars that will
be reported tomorrow
prior to my 10 a.m brief
it's important that everybody understand
that there are also
additional ballots that are pending
outside
of what i just described so i'm briefly
going to go through those
the provisional uh ballots that were
cast during the early voting and
election day
first announcement that i need to make
is that the posting that was placed on
our website
election night and yesterday was
incorrect
we determined that our tabulation
software was
incorrectly duplicating those records
and so the
000 that you may have seen on our
website is an incorrect number that has
been corrected
and the post that is out on our website
now at www.clarkcountymd.gov forward
slash quote
is correct and those professional
ballots number
a little over 60 000.
we have to coordinate very closely to
the secretary of state
we are a bottom up not a top-down voter
registration jurisdiction
and so all 17 counties need to send
information to the secretary because
there's not one single database
that we all draw from we all have our
own and so in coordinating with the
secretary of state we're awaiting
instructions from them on when to send
our provisional listing up to them
because we need to be absolutely certain
that nobody who's passed their
provisional ballot here in clark county
has done so in another county
so we're waiting instructions from them
on when to send that report so we can
make that verification
staff is still currently working on all
those provisional dollars to make
determinations as to whether the voter
was
eligible to cast that provisional ballot
that work will be ready once you notify
the secretary of state and it is an
automated process to pass those
provisional ballots into the tabulation
system
we have a group of voters who are id
required
for one reason or another the deadline
for those voters to get back to us
is friday november 6th at 5 pm
so that is another group of ballots that
we will need to
put into the system once they have come
in to provide their
id the us mail will continue to deliver
so starting tomorrow through next
tuesday which is the last day for us to
receive
a mail ballot that's been postmarked
november 3rd we will continue to receive
mail
so again those ballots are also separate
from what i previously reported
the cure process in the battle which is
statutory required for those voters who
have been notified the either did not
sign their ballot
or their signature did not match in our
system
they have until thursday november 12th
to cure that ballot
the last day that we can tabulate and
send ballots into the system
is november 12th so
that night we will stay here until we
are done entering ballots into the
system because statute clearly
tells us that we must be done counting
by that date
with that information uh we hope that
i've clarified a lot of the questions
we are anticipating to have the bulk of
our mail ballot
that have been received into the system
by saturday
or sunday those ballots that are coming
in through the u.s mail or
that are being cured will be a small
number and we will continue to put those
in but
the bulk of our ballots we're hoping
will be read by saturday or sunday
this weekend and again we won't complete
until november 12th with all those other
ballots and service exceptions
but with that information i've got a
short period of time here where i can
answer some questions
my response is that we are not aware of
any improper ballots that are being
processed
i think it's important for the entire
country to understand that mail ballots
on this scale is very new to the state
of nevada
we made a decision here to provide as
much access as we possibly could as a
result of the pandemic
and our processes run a little bit
slower
we also have to make sure that our data
is being updated because we need to
prevent
people from voting flights in the system
and so we have to scan those in as well
received so that it updates the database
so our in-person voters
can't have voted twice we're still
receiving information from our election
day laptops that'll be complete today
we're going to update and make sure that
all of the information was downloaded
from all 1300 of those laptops that were
used on election day
to make sure that the automated system
will reject mail ballots for somebody
who had voted
so our goal here in clark county is not
to count fast
we want to make sure that we're being
accurate the results in the state of
nevada obviously are going to be very
important to the entire country
i went through a long process
because they're not available sir there
are many steps in the process
so processes that we run it through our
agilis machine
then there are two manual processes then
it goes to the accounting board
and then it goes about over 60 thousand
ballots
i need you to speak up sir i can't hear
you you talked about over 60 000 ballots
that were outstanding that the 51
thousand have
already been counted and that tomorrow
you'll give this information before your
10 a.m week
but if they're already counted why give
the information i did not say they were
already counting
i said today the staff has prepared to
count fifty one thousand dollars that
are ready to be counted today
those will be reported tomorrow at 10
a.m right there
there are more folks i really need you
all to speak up i cannot hear you
i've done more than 60 000 provisional
ballots does that include the number
that need their id
certified by private or is that a
separate number i didn't know for id
those are separate and that's why i
listed in my statement that those are
separate from the numbers that are
reported
first what is that number though
required we don't i don't have that one
to summarize
that's a number that i can't give you i
can't predict you what's going to come
from the u.s men
so i deliberately went through all of
these numbers and i was hoping that you
all would
uh take the information that i'm
providing but there's a set number
of ballots that we know are available to
be processed
and that's the 60 63 000 then i
mentioned all of the other
additional dollars so we again
again we plan to cut to be able to have
counted the majority
of our mail ballots by saturday or
sunday and then all of those
other ballots that were statutorily
limited
i can't count all the mail dollars that
i have now and we have to continue to
accept them until tuesday
november
that is correct
is
i personally dealt with ms still she
brought her claim to me
we renewed the ballot and in our opinion
it's her signature
we also gave her an opportunity to
provide a statement
if she wanted to object to that and
provide challenge to that she refused to
do so
a member of the nevada secretary of
state's office investigation team also
interviewed her and they had no issue
with the assistance that we tried to
give him
during your press conference yesterday
there were rallies outside of the
building yesterday evening
are you concerned with your own safety
what is being done
i can tell you that my wife and my
mother are very concerned for me but
we have security here we have law
enforcement who are protecting us i am
concerned for the safety of my staff
we're putting measures into place uh to
make sure that
we have the security that's necessary
again we're going to begin to monitor
uh the vehicles that they come in to
make sure that they should be here and
that they're parking properly so that we
don't prevent
our employees from having an issue
getting in and out of the facility but i
i i feel safe we're going to be okay
we're going to continue to count we will
not allow anyone to stop us from doing
what our duty is
and counting dollars yes
violation of their own rules because
that they cannot be allowed to observe
closely
all the accounting in the process
the first part of your question relates
to action that was taken by the nevada
legislature
i don't make policy i'm simply an
administrator so the nevada legislature
acted in the summer
and we carried through exactly what they
prescribed for us to do
as far as your second issue that it
should have been litigated
and the judge ruled in our favor
do you have any reports of people voting
those are reports that we're going to
generate after the election once we
start getting ready to do our candidates
so that's information that i'll have
available once we've done all of our
work counted all the ballots
and if we have enough troopers we're
definitely going out uh
to arrest these people because those are
obviously illegal actions but
that's an activity that needs to take
place once we've done counting
and getting the canvas done um
most of these voters have been notified
and they actually voted because they
voted provisionally and were told they
didn't have the id that they needed in
order to do that
these are also male ballot voters who
are also notified that they needed to
provide an id
on the envelope that sent out to them
and they felt to do so so
they've been notified and the deadline
is tomorrow at 5 pm
i know that there are several people who
are working
to actively reach out to those voters
it depends on the status of our
metabolic process we are running ships
in certain areas
uh so we can
vary from 5 am up to 10 or 11 o'clock at
night
we don't run the 24-hour shift that you
see running in other states because
the work that comes through on the mail
ballot process is very deliberate
as it moves forward and so we complete
the work that's
done in each stage and then the next day
it carries forward to the next again i
am precise
what i'm trying to report here is that
clark county looks like
we'll be able to have the majority of
our mail ballots by saturday or sunday
however there are other ballots as a
result of the statutory requirements
that
we'll have to continue to reap that we
have to take balance until next tuesday
these three weeks absolutely
we're going to coincide with the
secretary of state i think it's very
important that as a state all 17 of the
counties
are working to coordinate with the
secretary who's our chief election
officer
so she has reported that she put out
today and he followed suit
reporting today if the secretary makes a
decision not to report
from here on out we are going to have to
report
so if we have results from reports we
will do it on a daily basis as i
mentioned
we're going to do a 10 a.m brief to give
you all an opportunity to ask questions
and our updates should be posted prior
to that
any individual who had an issue with
their male ballot should contact us
prior to election day
we are here to help the voters i have
been on many zoom interviews
media interviews many uh organizational
groups throughout the county
letting them know that if you have an
issue with your ballot whatever it may
be
five vote however they're past that
problem the election is over
uh we're in the process of counting them
right there
the percentage of the total votes
counted right now
you know that's available on our website
i don't have that number right off the
top of my head but you can quickly see
that on our website
yesterday
i'm sorry ma'am i can't be a part of
hearing you here
and then in addition we add
regardless of any reports that you're
referring to the numbers that i just
gave you
are the ones you should go with don't
try to calculate it for yourself
i just told you that there are 63 262
and then there are exceptions right so i
can't answer any of your questions
because you're drawing from data that i
didn't calculate no i'm drawing from
data from the secretary of state
that's not what i've used to generate i
purposely set up this interview so that
you can make sure and clear this up
you're drawing your data from somebody
else somewhere else and you want me to
answer according to that number
i can't that's why i gave you this
information no i understand i'm looking
for i'm going to ask questions
right here
i can't give you a probability on that
what i can tell you is that we're firm
in our
a commitment to making sure that we're
processing dollars with high integrity
and state of the battle
a lot of that that depends on anybody
who's aware of something they feel that
may have been the ferris they need to
notify our
office and look at the nevada secretary
of state involved investigating that but
we're doing everything we can to uphold
the integrity of the process here
[Music]
now
absolutely we're very committed here we
have a strong
history in clark county of leading in
our processes and using technology
and working to keep things high in
integrity with everything
that i do and we do as a team credit to
my staff for their commitment as well in
the hours of work
but what i really want to also hit home
on and this is for election
administrators across the country i'm
sure they agree with me
we're not concerned with reading as fast
as we can we are concerned with making
sure that we're accurate and what we'll
report
because this is a very important
election in the state of nevada you may
make the decision for the president
so take that very seriously and we will
make sure
that we're doing everything
that possible most should be counted by
tomorrow
that's not what i said i've said it many
times
clark county is looking like we will
complete the bulk of our mail dollar
account
by saturday and sunday after that there
are several exceptions
and they need to statute i i can't i
can't know what i'm going to receive in
the mail next sunday monday or not
sunday monday and tuesday
i'm statutory required to complete
ballots if they're postmarked by the
third
all of the exceptions that i mentioned
that the scholarship will be counted
anybody that was eligible in the castle
ballot have provided us anything they
need to survive
the ballot will be counted by november
12th
yeah i don't have observers it's the
general public that comes in and
observes i i don't know
a member of the trump team said he was
turned away when he tried to observe
what's the policy on
that man
earlier at a press conference a member
of the trump team named mr prudham
said he was turned away from observing
do you have any record of that or would
you turn someone away if they wanted to
observe
absolutely not we've been working close
with all parties who've been interested
in observing our activities in fact
we've gone above and beyond what the
statute calls for us to do
the only thing clark county needs to do
part by law
provide access to anyone who wants to
observe us county
we realized with the engagement by the
general public in this election
that they were going to be concerned and
probably want to see more so we as a
courtesy provided more
observation opportunities in other rooms
now
these groups have also been contacted on
a regular basis
and they continue to say that we're not
communicating with them we started
communicating with them in the month of
august
and september and we made clear to them
exactly what we would do
we set up a schedule to count and it's a
worst case scenario
because we want to make sure that we've
got all of our bases covered
and we're going to have staff available
to complete each task
each step every day obviously my staff
is getting better at what they do
because they've been doing it for over
20 days now
so if we finish before our scheduled
time
and there's no more work they're done so
we have notified observers that come up
there's nothing to observe and we've
even gone so far as to tour them
and take them to see the area to confirm
that there's nothing going on
unfortunately there are some
observers that come through that take it
upon themselves to go into areas that
they're not allowed to do
interact with our workers but they're
not allowed to do we clearly
communicate to them exactly what they
can and can't do with observers so no we
have done everything we possibly can in
clark county
to allow services
one more question we're gonna take one
of them
votes are in the system
some of them they're grouped in
different areas i can't tell you exactly
which ballots went in
dot com
what i'm telling you is exactly what we
know we have left this could be a
combination of drop-off dollars
that's all we really have left
again in-person voting was reported on
election night that would be already
voting on election day all of the
in-person rules are in the system
thanks sir thank you very much we'll see
you tomorrow morning